I just want to say I come I have no
words to say how much I appreciate and I
mean you're literally a real-life
superhero thank you so I just want to
start with that what is it like what was
it like watching the film for the first
time I'm sure you've been asked that
yeah but it's just it's such an
incredible movie
yeah and it's your life yeah it's
surreal I mean I just never imagined
that the work I do would one day be the
subject of a major motion picture but
it's really gratifying and it's exciting
mostly because I've always been
persuaded that if people saw what I see
if they saw the inhumanity if they saw
the abuse of people's right if they saw
the unfairness they would be motivated
to act and I haven't had the ability to
just take people with me into jails into
prisons on the road and now for the
first time people will have the
opportunity to see some of what I've
seen and the performances are so amazing
they're so incredible that you also get
to see the humanity and the dignity of
the people I've represented and that for
me is really exciting I'm just really
thrilled that people will get closer to
this world where I think there's a great
need for reform and change and I'm
hoping that this film will inspire that
kind of conversation I'm also hoping
just from my perspective that this film
can shine a light on what you do and
maybe help you get more resources yeah
to help you yeah further fight well
thank you I mean it's definitely been a
struggle
you know when you represent the poor and
the condemned the incarcerated and the
disfavored you know people are somewhat
skeptical if they're not outright
hostile and we've had to deal with that
hostility and I hope people understand
the value of the kind of work that we do
I'm still persuaded that we have a
criminal justice system that treats you
better if you're rich and guilty than if
you're poor and innocent that's not
something we should be proud of that's
something we need to fix and I'd like to
think that the work that we do and
others like us it's critical to the
solution and and I do hope we can get
more support you bring up something
which someone it's very frustrating when
I
watch the news and I see very rich
people who've done horrible things get a
month sentence or just nothing and then
people who stolen a pack of gum or you
know they're sentenced to seven years
it's straight-up [ __ ] yeah well that
we have a system that's very shape I
went at wealth and when I got involved
in this work because I met people on
death row who were literally dying for
legal assistance they could not get the
help they need and the absence of that
ability to get that help is what
condemned them and you're right our
scheme and our system is very very
slanted I'm currently representing
people who've been sentenced to life
imprisonment for writing a bad check for
40 or 50 dollars I'm representing people
who've been sentenced to life
imprisonment without parole for simple
possession of marijuana and I don't
think most people could defend these
sentences but it's what happens when you
create a system that is so unresponsive
to the needs of the poor and people of
color so that has to change and what I'm
hoping is that we'll all be motivated to
achieve that kind of change um my last
thing for you every movie you have to
take like you have to sort of fact and
fiction put it all you have to make a
movie mm-hmm what was maybe something
that you were you were maybe wished
could have been in there that you know
what I mean but yeah the two-hour run
yeah yeah well in my book which I hope
people will read I talk a lot about
representing children who've been
prosecuted as adults we have 13 states
in America that have no minimum age for
trying children as adults and so I've
been representing 13 and 14 year old
kids who be condemned to die in prison
life without parole and we shot a scene
where Michael B actually goes to a jail
to help a young child who's been placed
in an adult facility where he's been
badly badly treated I really wanted that
scene in the film because I wanted
people to know that we have this problem
of child prosecution as adults but you
know again to two hours and 15 is long
and so I hope people read the book
there's a whole lot more to talk about
than what's presented in the film
and I hope viewers will kind of explore
that by reading the book